hello everyone and welcome to the grand
master lecture I'm very happy about
these lectures because I get to choose
what the content of the lecture is going
to be about and I think the biggest
story in the world of chess today is the
extraordinary success of a 22 year old
table you on Acharya wanna if you look
at his rating he's had one of these
things that we all just dream about his
rating just keeps going up and up and up
and up and there's never really been
there's been a few relatively short
periods where he draw the flatlined but
what has been extraordinary his
continued progress and about who I was
going to say mmm eight months ago six
months ago start of the year what will
you I was thinking that we're going to
be seeing the era of Magnus Carlsen full
stop end of story Magnus has hasn't
simply been magnificent he's been in the
world's number one player in the world
through I'm gonna guess the mate for
years maybe even five possibly longer he
won the world championship against this
one ofone and on an absolutely
convincing style he won the match
undefeated which is about as convincing
as you could possibly be his gap between
his nearest rival and his nearest rival
for the last two or three years has had
been Levon Aronian
of Armenia and the gap between them was
well over 80 rating points so Magnus
looked
fantastic I was thinking gosh I would be
shocked if we didn't see Magnus
dominating chess for the next decade
Magnus himself is very young 23 ish
there is about that sounds right um a
year as several years younger than Levon
Aronian and so my goodness you know
sky's the limit what will this guy do
reset all the record books he surpassed
Gary's Garry Kasparov's highest peak
rating ever and he very rarely if ever
loses as for example his match with
Vichy so again you know if you had asked
me six months ago ten months ago you
know who was going to challenge Magnus I
would ask rhetorically I don't know
who's going to challenge Magnus looks
really it looks like a layup the guy is
just unbeatable then along comes hobby
on a car you wanna making his steady
steady steady steady progress in the
month of August we had here in st. Louis
the Sinquefield Cup fantastic tournament
easily one of the most enjoyable events
I've ever been a part of I was proud to
say I was really a part of the history
here I was one of the commentators along
with Jennifer and Maryse for the
Sinquefield Cup and everyday I am not
kidding every single day we would come
in and there was only one question our
whole show got taken over by the
question the streak Fabiano had a streak
he won his first game and they'd sing
field cup his second not too bad
his third whoa this is amazing is for it
okay this is completely ridiculous is
fifth it's off the chart let's start
analyzing the history and who had the
greatest results ever six seventh and he
took over our entire show Bob you on a
car you wanna at the end of the event
was clear first eight and a half out of
ten he won his first seven games was
winning in the eighth and ninth games
those two games were draw and he drew
the final game to score his final eight
and a half he became elite frogged over
LaVon Iranian Levon Aronian became the
number two player in the world when he
left st. Louis the gap was about 40
rating points or thereabout in other
words he had half the distance between
Magnus of number one and Magnus's near
rival number two was suddenly only 40
points he went to Bilbao in Spain where
he was playing for a club there in a
major major tournament and he gained 15
rating points I was like whoa completely
unstoppable the closing the gap yet
again to a very very narrow margin I
think it's now at that point about 25
points
he five Yannick Ariana car you Anna is
now in a Grand Prix tournament a feat a
Grand Prix tournament in Azerbaijan in
the capital city of Baku where he's
doing extremely well yet again and the
whole story these days in the world of
chess is unstoppable Caruana
he's just doing a magnificent
magnificent things at this at this
moment gosh I didn't see today's results
but at the moment that I've meant to be
lecturing he was tied for first with
Boris Gelfand
at +2 after five rounds of play meaning
that he has scored two victories more
than defeat he doesn't have any losses
so he has two wins and three draws after
five rounds giving him a score three and
a half out of five he's great he's
gained yet again
additional five points and I believe
he's now somewhere in the vicinity of a
mere 15 point difference between himself
and Magnus his opponent for this game
again is being played in Azerbaijan in
the capital city of Azerbaijan Baku and
his opponent is the highest-rated
Azerbaijani player I'm going to make an
attempt to describe his name check-check
we are many Dhara chakra are mammy Dhara
for obvious reasons we call him Shaq
Shaq rearm Amidala is azerbaijan's
top-rated chess player in the world's
top ten at 2764 Fabiana was white and
Fabiano opened d4 so d4 d5 c4 c6 Knight
f3 Knight f6 and we get arguably the
most popular defense at the highest
levels of chess the Slav interestingly
enough when I was very young I played
the Slav defense as black left it for
other pastures Queens gambit accepted
Queens gambit declined etc etc in 2012 I
had a walk I had a match against former
world champion Anatoly Karpov
and when I was analyzing Karpov s--
games in preparation for the match I
decided to play the slob defense as
black as well and Anatoly always likes
this setup and on his fourth move he has
a near religion religious experience
plays III and this is the position I
prepare for as black and it's what
Fabiana played as well
Bishop g4 well it's clear that with
these two pawns on c6 and d5 and in
anticipation of being able to play E 754
it becomes passively placed behind his
pawns after each 76 so Bishop g4 the
most popular move for Black Knight c3
developing a piece eise evan EXO we see
instantly our understanding is very
clear that the bishop on c8 is outside
of the pawn chain it's very active there
away we go
so from White's point of view his
position has a two defects which I tried
to exploit when I play with Anatoly
Karpov two defects the first is well
whether it's it's terrible or not that
Knight is in a pen and as much as the
knight would like to go for example to
the square e 5 well at the moment we're
in a pen and we can't do that the second
slight defect is that the bishop on c1
is impeded by his own pawn on e3 unlike
black who was clever enough to bring his
bishop outside of his pawn chain white
was less clever but there are very
specific reasons why white players
including anatoly karpov
liked this position for white and that
and it starts with the move Queen b3
give me the pawn give me the rook
so Queen b3 it breaks the pin with a
gain of tempo against the pawn on b7 odd
this position has been played in I'm
going to say numerous Grandmaster games
and Queen b6 is the most popular way of
meeting this threat of Queen takes b7
fair enough
now Knight h4 has recently become
an extremely popular move and that is
the move that car you want it in fact
played it looks a little strange night
h4 I mean the most direct move for
example is Knight to e5 now that the pin
is broken why not bring the knight
centralize it in the middle of the board
very natural move also opening up the
possibility of Knight captures the
Bishop on g4 that the reason is is that
as attractive as this move appears to be
the knight in the middle of the ball
makes a very impressive sight after the
move Bishop h5 it's strange but the
knight actually becomes a target for
blacks pieces black is preparing to play
the move knight on b8 to d7 to just
simply try to trade this Knight off the
board and after for example might be 87
if you trade he recaptures and nothing
special has happened in the meanwhile
you still that is to say white has not
so yet has not yet sold the question of
what does he intend to do with his
bishop on c1 is it going to go to d2 and
if they had answer is yes
where hence after the bishop comes to d2
however the move chosen by Fabiano has a
very specific ID in mind that very
specific idea is that white wants to
capture this bishop and his intent is to
play h3 g4 force the bishop back to g6
and then to capture the bishop on g6 so
very popular move for example is the
move Knight d7
and after the rather forcing variation
h3 Bishop back g4 Bishop back Knight
takes pawn takes Bishop g2 from White's
point of view White has one the two
bishops maybe maybe maybe at some moment
he might be inclined to play the move g5
followed by e for trying to open this
diagonal as well as his bishop on c1
Grandmaster practice has shown that in
general White's results from this exact
position are favorable for white yeah
it's not the end of the story of course
but that's that's what the Grandmaster
practice is shown so Bishop h5 this
looks like a very sophisticated move and
in some ways it is it basically says
okay what are you going to do Fabiana
says well I'm going to take your knight
I'm going to play g4 and I'm going to
take your Bishop on h5 mommy-daughter
off has a very deserved reputation for
ultra aggression when you when you look
up an aggression aggressive chess
grandmaster and encyclopedia
Jess there's this photo h3 with thee so
for example here if we move our night
after the move g4 we simply transpose
into that variation I mentioned Mommy
die-offs
said no I'm going to play the move g5
and that was the reason I dropped back
with my bishop is now if you move your
knight for example well you're not going
to win my bishop and maybe I could
double your pawns or maybe do something
else so g7 g5 was mommy-daughter offs
play and a Fabiana said okay I've wasted
some time I've moved my knight back and
forth but I've induced a serious
weakness
if it's my turn white intends to capture
this pawn on g5 h 7h 6 c4 c5 so what
white is hoping is that he will force
black to trade Queens by the way any
questions any questions so far
does everything make a kind of a sense
it's it's flowing for you in case of
this trade white would be very very
happy to make this trade because
although these pawns are doubled for the
moment White's intention is as simple as
b4 b5 take and another b4 b5 and getting
a very serious Queen side initiative
also we still haven't given up on our
idea of Knight e5 certainly a Shaq had
no intention of trading Queens it
doesn't fit with his ultra aggressive
style he dropped back with Queen c7 and
now from Shaq's point of view he says
okay you provoked me into making a week
and that's what g5 but I provoked you
and if I could if black is able to play
b7 b6 that moves c4 c5 may turn out to
be a target for blacks pieces Bishop d3
with this move Bishop d3 what White's
intention is to play g4 force the bishop
back trade bishops creating double pawns
here play Knight e5 or Queen c2
attacking upon that would appear on the
g6 Square rook g8
Black's intention is to meet the move g4
with Bishop back trading bishops and
recapturing with his rook Queen c2 so
White's intention with this move Queen
c2 it is any tickles with the move b7 b6
white intends to be able to defend his
pawn on c5 or rather to support his pawn
on c5 with a move like b2 b4 Knight be
87 everything has a flow before setting
up for just having an initiative in
space on the Queen site notice that
white is intending to solve what is
passive Bishop is doing what white is
hoping is that black will prematurely
advance in the center with the move e5
so for example the move e5 here would be
welcomed by white after e5 Knight takes
e5 Knight takes e5 D takes e5 Queen
takes e5 Bishop b2 and notice that
suddenly this Bishop that really didn't
have any effective influence in the game
is suddenly on this beautiful diagonal
white already has a winning threat of
Knights e3 e4 with a discovered attack
against blacks Queen so E 5 would be
really a premature break and instead
Bishop e7 Bishop b2 and now mammy lived
up to his reputation and he struck out
very boldly very aggressively with the
move g5 g4 which in a certain sense
forces white onto the defensive that in
a higher sense really says that with
this move g3 g4 I'm burning bridges I'm
playing
very very boldly for the attack and that
was his choice
Shaq could have played and arguably as
you would see the result of this game
and what happened perhaps he should have
chose to be to be a little bit less bold
and simply play Bishop back to g6 so
that on any trades black I think has a
more or less even position maybe I would
prefer to play the white piece as a
smidgen but nothing exceptional
however g4 definitely did make for a
very interesting game and after H takes
g4 rook takes g4 White has a problem how
on earth is he going to defend the pawn
on g2 on the other hand this rook on h1
is nicely positioned it attacks this
Bishop on h5 and should it retreat well
there's a pawn to be grubbed and I do
like grubbing pawns on the H six squared
but in the meanwhile okay white figure
out how you're going to defend against
the move rook takes g2 how would the
class defend against this capture
indeed Austin says my foot the first
instinct is g3 and with this move g3 you
might think to yourself am i falling
into a problem after rook takes g3 right
you go not too sure if you take this
rook Bishop takes is a very reasonable
possibility and this Bishop attacks this
rook on h1 and this pawn on g3 is under
attack as well and you might just have a
little regrets that you're allowing your
opponent this possibility and in fact g3
rook takes g3 works out well for black
so we have to find another move beside
g3 now Bishop f1 is a move we just have
to shy away from for the very simple
reason that well we're we're going
backwards we're going backwards
and that leaves King f1 and our first
instinct is well we're not so pleased
about the move King f1 because in the
first place we move our king we don't
castle but on the but on the other hand
the more you look at the move King f1
the more you could become attracted to
the idea
simply put within the absence of a pawn
on g5 it suddenly becomes compelling for
white play 92 Knight f4 there is a there
are a few defenders on the Kings side if
things get really tough after castles
and rook doubles up against this pawn on
g2 why there's a simple defense to be
had in the move Knight II won so after
we overcome our initial revulsion
to the move King f1 we start to warm up
to what it does in the meanwhile blacks
pieces aren't really that great like
this Bishop on h5 which is kind of
scaring us on the other hand ties down
this night my can't move rook takes if
the bishop moves well we can grab this
pawn as previously mentioned and again
there are certain defects this isn't a
crystal clear attack that's going on for
black nonetheless Mehmet a Shack castle
with the idea with a straightforward
idea I should say of doubling up his
rooks and it's like go go go what are
you going to do so nightie-night c3 e to
the knight on on c3 isn't particularly
effective in terms of defending its King
suddenly it comes back to the square e
too with the idea that maybe it could go
to f4 to attack this Bishop maybe this
night will go to e5 thanks to this
Bishop being open we can stick a knight
in the middle of the board so ideas like
95 Knight f4 or ninety five ninety three
White has defensive ideas and black has
committed himself rook g8 and here we go
Knight f4 suddenly when we see this
night making this beautiful transfer to
the f4 square we kind of get a little
bit happier more pieces defending whites
King if we can force the Bishop to go
back well we could take that Bishop and
take that pawn or we could take that
Bishop and take that pawn if you go
Bishop back and after Bishop takes pawn
takes suddenly your rooks are cut off
black really has no choice he must
sacrifice in exchange and it scares the
bejesus out of us when he does so but
Fabiana had
and calculated a very clean reputation
at first sight and the first blush I
began to wonder about White's plan first
of all we've seen these types of
exchange sacrifices all the time and
Sicilians just you put a rook on c8 you
take a knight on c3 and you're a happy
camper is black why aren't you a happy
camper here as well those triple pawn
formation on the F 4 F 3 F 2 squares
they seem like really really nice
targets Queen takes f4 there goes one of
them now the move King e2 and we start
to have ponder the issue for a moment
first of all these ponds as we can as
doubled as they are they control some
vital squares they protect III g3e for
g4 furthermore this pawn on f2 protects
us against a check on the second rank
with this move king e 2 furthermore
we're preparing to play the move Queen
d2 offering a trade of Queens quite
clearly black is not interested in
trading Queens as that would see his
attack seriously diminished what to do
how to continue the attack
don't all answer at once rook t2 you're
channeling mammy Daraa you bet rook g2
bringing that guy hoping to be able to
blast away with this move rook g2 we can
see ideas of Knight g4 we can see ideas
of Knight e4 we can see ideas of Queen
g3 and when you see those ideas as white
it's easy to panic and this guy Fabiano
not only is he a great attacker he has
nerves of steel you've seen all of these
attacking moves by black he drops back
with the Queen he says Queens right
green tricked you got no note no time to
play Knight g4 or 94 offering a great
acquaintance what can black play
correct queen g3 I mean there's no other
reasonable move if black were to drop
back with this Queen well in the first
place I could probably chase away the
rook but after Queen drops back maybe
white should just take this pawn with
his rook on h6 and maybe it's white
who's getting in some kind of attack
against blacks King
hence the move Queen g3 with a threat of
rook or Queen captures f2 check winning
so what can white play
how are you going to defend that pawn on
f2
what moves come to mind got to defend
that pawn on f2 cannot afford to see
that pawn disappear
as I see it there's only three
reasonable moves the first reasonable
move it's just as defend upon with the
rook but when you move the rook away
from the h-file after a move for example
rook f1 then black will quickly play
Knight to h5 and Knight to f4 check to
the King and gain threats the second
move that I think is most credible let's
put it that way is the move Queen III
that certainly is a nice move it
protects the pawn f2 it keeps the h5 it
keeps that Knight honest now the knight
can't really jump we could take it if a
knight jumped here we could take it and
it looks like white is as we would say
consolidating until you stop and think
for a moment and go oh my what about the
move e5 should I be fearful that maybe
just maybe black has some dangerous
attack against my king the knight coming
here I'm not saying that this is a
dangerous attack against the king but
it's a type of opportunity that black is
looking for the third move and the move
that was chosen by Fabiana is a clean
cold killer defensive move Queen f1 is
the clean cold defense of Killer Queen
f1 protects the pawn on f2 the kit
contains as well an insidious threat
what is that what is what what does what
is White's threat after the move Queen
f1
yeah exactly
if black makes a pausing move for
example like h5 says I don't want to
lose my H pond check this out
Queen takes Queen takes and that trade
of of a queen for rook is now inevitable
and the entire attack for black stops
you trade off that Queen on g3 in that
rook on g2 and there's nothing just
absolutely cold-blooded nothing stone
cold
so with this move Queen f1 and realizing
that oh my gosh Queen takes g2 Queen
takes g2 Rupe g1 I can resign mammy Dara
had to reach into his bag of tricks and
say hey I've I've invested my structure
when I play g4 I've invested oops I beg
your pardon I have invested in exchange
there's no turning back
Knight g4 no turning back with this move
black of course reinforces his attack
against the f2 pot and white says thank
you very much I'll have that one okay so
how to continue the attack Queen takes
g4 check King / Queen f4 check King back
now that little repetition is oftentimes
made in tournament chess because you get
a bonus of let's say 30 seconds or so
for repeating of the position now with
this move King e1 basically what white
is saying is hey I'm now a rook ahead
and if it's my turn my intention is to
play the move oops excuse me my
intention is to play the move Bishop on
d3 to e2
driving you back further I'm a rook
ahead do something so Shaq
true to his nature let's keep it going
95 okay with this move black is heading
for an opportunity to force white into a
discover check by Knight f3 and you
wanna said I'm going to stop you I'm
going to play Bishop to e2 attacking
your queen now if you jump with your
knight to f3 check and the first place I
could probably just take it and play
Queen e2 or in the second place I could
perhaps to simply move my king and all
your pieces are kind of boxed in and in
a pin Queen efore with Shaq's move King
d1 Bishop g5 doing his best to activate
all of his pieces as much as he possibly
can and Fabiana said thank you very much
I'll have that one to him just
cold-bloodedly just taking everything
that black has on offer and now white is
a rook and a bishop to the good Queen
takes B far a very scary move indeed not
just only with the threat of Queen takes
b2 but with the additional threat of
check mate in one move Queen d2 Fabiana
says I got a move that meets both
threats King c2 defends the bishop and
the secondly after Queen beat d2 check
I'll slip away with my king and thanks
to my extra material that is to say I'm
a bishop and a rook to the good what are
you going to do about it
Shak said give me this pawn and give me
this pawn
so Fabiana said well that was okay with
me I give you back a couple of ponds but
in the meanwhile my king is not White's
King is now in safety and after Queen d1
Queen to e3 rookie one there's basically
no further threats that will black him
legitimately make against White's King
in the first place he could just perhaps
bring his bishop back or in the next
case just play a four rook a three
activating his rook and thanks to his
extra material of a rook and Bishop this
is a winning position and in fact Shaq
gave up the ghost and he resigned he
might have continued a move or two
further for example he might have wanted
to play a move like Queen d3 Queenie for
Czech Bishop d3 queen bee - rookie -
blocking the thread along the second
rank and again the material deficit of a
rook and a bishop is simply too large
and so Shaq resigned a simple game yeah
that's the way it looks like but at the
board to find all of those really
excellent powerhouse defensive moves
including Queen F 1 and not to be
intimidated by blacks attack it made a
very powerful impression on me this game
did by car you wanna and furthermore
it's one of those games where I ask
myself internally where was White's
mistake I mean white I the eye does not
a single move in this game that I have
an argument with white played absolutely
great at every stage in this in this
game I think that White's
play was superb and that's why we're say
today Bob you on a car you wanna is the
toast of the chest world the talk of the
town
pretty impressive any questions come on
now then I'll shout out at once but
don't but would you agree with me that
this was an impressive game like mos def
I know
exactly for the audience online I was
saying that the class is say you know
considering what pressure White's King
is under and the reality is 99% and I'll
even toss that in of tournament players
nevermind on tournament players 99% of
tournament players would be worried and
and to play so many precise moves at
each and every stage of the game you
just sometimes in the words of Joel
Benjamin you just gotta tip your hat and
say well done and that was really really
well done and we're seeing why people
are now saying that the matches of the
future and maybe the greatest rivalries
in the modern chest will be between
Fabiano and Magnus that certainly would
appear that way after a game like this
so I thank you all for joining me on
this beautiful day here in st. Louis and
what can I say we're I'm looking forward
to more the trees of this type where we
just kind of take our breath away and go
Wow pretty cool thank you all
you